Now that we understand files and content workflows a little bit better, let's talk a little bit
about the Unreal Engine interface.
So we have UI and components here made up of the toolbar, the modes panel, content browser,
viewport, world outline and details panel.
So just to touch upon what each one of these is, on the top we've got the toolbar here
and you can select the different modes that you want to edit your scene in.
So whether you want to be in content editing mode with the assets that you're placing down,
whether you want to be in landscape mode or foliage mode, and we have a few different
modes to select from here.
And then we can also open the blueprints from this toolbar, we can create cinematics from
this toolbar and we can also play through the experience or package the project from
this toolbar as well.
So and also just save the project, which is a good habit to get into.
And we've got the modes pane on the left hand side here and then depending on which mode
you had selected from the toolbar, it will give you relevant options.
So as you're cycling through the different modes, this window will be updating with the
tools that are available at your disposal when going through the modes.
When we talk about the content browser at the bottom, this is where you're housing all
of your content that you've imported from your DCC app.
So depending on your naming conventions and your file structures, you'll be able to find
the relevant information.
And it's also worth noting that we have a filtering out of content.
So I'll just show you that quickly in the engine so you can see the filter because I
think that's useful to touch upon.
So if we're trying to find certain content inside of our content browser, there is a
favorites tab, first of all, which you can add favorites to.
That's quite a useful functionality.
Specifically on the filtering that I was talking about, if you're trying to find a level to
open which is inside your content, maybe you can scroll through to the relevant folders
and find the information that you need.
Maybe you go to the levels tab and this is a level that I currently have open.
But if, for example, you've got your level saved in multiple places, I can actually filter
out this content either through searching the content, if you're using consistent prefixes
with your files, maybe you can search the prefix and find the content or you can actually
filter out the content based on the content type.
So you could select a blueprint to find blueprints.
I've selected level here and if I click level, it actually creates this level filter here
and it shows all the levels.
And because I've got content selected, which is the parent folder, it actually shows me
all the levels that are present within this project.
So if you need a quicker way to find your content, obviously good naming convention
and folder structure is the primary thing.
But if you are struggling to find certain bits of information, do consider using the
filter tab because it's very powerful and very useful when you're trying to find certain
bits of content.
And hopefully that gives you a little bit more idea about how to navigate the content
browser.
On the top right, we have the world outliner, which you'll see all the actors that are
in your scene will be present here, which you can scroll through.
You can create hierarchies here where you can child other actors to parents and just
also add folders and collect everything together and name everything correctly so your scene
is well organized.
You'll see that there's a layers and levels tab next to the world outliner there.
You can find these from the window option, sorry, at the top left of your editor next
to file, edit and then window.
And you can open different windows depending on what you need.
The layers tab, essentially you can add actors to layers that you can set the visibility
of so you can hide and unhide content at runtime.
And then levels tab is if you have streaming content, maybe if you want to stream in a
whole lot of content at a certain point through the experience, you can do that using levels.
But yeah, the world outliner is the main thing that we're highlighting there.
Then you've got your details panel at the bottom right here.
Again, you've got world settings next to the details panel, which you can find from the
window setting at the top left of the editor there.
But to specifically focus on the details panel, whenever you select an actor inside this scene,
inside the viewport, you can see the relevant details that you can edit.
So say for example, if you selected a static mesh in your scene, you'll be able to set
the material or the scale.
Maybe you want to set something specific to its rendering properties.
You can find all these options in the details panel.
And then finally, we've got the main viewport here.
So you navigate the viewport and again, using those hotkeys and quick tips that we had displayed
before, you'll be able to navigate through the scene.
We have viewport settings, which I'll touch upon in more detail in a second at the top
left of the viewport there where it says viewport settings.
And then you got your transform tools and snaps in the top right of the viewport where
you can cycle through scale, rotation and movement.
And so you can actually toggle through those transforms just pressing spacebar in your
editor.
So if you have a static mesh selected and you tap spacebar, you can cycle through the
location rotation and scale widget.
It helps you really quickly manipulate the content there.
And you've also got different grid snapping properties, which you can change the grid
from 10 units to 5 units depending on the snapping.
And to give you a little bit of idea about this widget that I was referring to, if I
go over to a chair, for example, and I can see the pivot and again, just to navigate
touching on these hot tips that I was using before, I'm using right mouse button to pan
my camera.
So just pressing and holding right mouse button.
I'm using my left mouse button to go backwards and forwards.
I'm holding down both mouse buttons to go up and down.
So you can see that as I move around, I'm just holding left click.
Now I'm holding right both and now I'm holding right mouse button.
So again, just cycle through the left mouse button, right mouse button and then both mouse
buttons to get a feel for navigating the scene.
But the specific toolbar that I was talking about is if I press spacebar, I can cycle
through the widgets here.
I can also set the snap sizes to 10, 5 and you'll see that 5 updates to 10, updates
to 15 and I'm actually using the bracket keys next to the enter key on my keyboard to actually
cycle that grid size, which I think is a really quick and useful way, especially when you're
working with a modular content that needs to snap together.
That can be really helpful when you're using the bracket keys.
And then you got rotation snapping, scaling snapping and also the camera speed.
So if you're navigating around your viewport, I'm holding down W, A, S and D on the keyboard
at different points to navigate around the scene.
If you feel like your camera is moving too quickly, you can bring the camera speed down.
Alternatively, you can see I'm now moving quite slowly around the scene.
Alternatively, you can drag it up.
If you want something a little bit more dynamic as well, as I'm right, I'm pressing and holding
my right mouse button to pan around the scene.
I'm also pressing W, A, S and D to move around.
If I'm trying to get to a certain part, I can actually use my mouse wheel to zoom faster
and slower.
So if you're navigating around and you use your mouse wheel button, it can actually really
help you move around the scene a bit quicker.
So just a few tips there of navigating the editor just in case they were useful to you.